so what are you looking forward to
tonight at Charlie the Chocolate Factory
Carlson I'm excited to hear the talented
kids I mean you know they always I mean
the children nowadays are becoming even
more talented because they're just such
a venturous mind so I'm excited to see
them kind of put that into the show
tonight and and see you know the
costumes and the sets and see you know
there's a big buzz about the show so I
know I'm sure it's gonna live up to it I
can tell you gonna have you mind blad
I've seen it already it's amazing did
you seen the previews okay
hi everyone's saying really really great
things in there I mean you can't turn
around without seeing signs about it so
and I have a lot of friends who are on
Broadway and I love coming to shows and
supporting this so I'm so excited you're
gonna be seeing Matthew Morrison walking
down here so yeah Charlie and Huck
refractories it's also a lot of birds
about which to arrow as well that's not
nice so what I wanted to know is how
does that feel becoming a series regular
the season two I'm so excited to be a
full-time part of the show because you
know it was nice to be on the show just
for a little bit that I was and now I
get to be a full-time and there's a lot
in store a lot of a lot that the comic
book fans are really gonna enjoy and a
lot of unexpected relationships that are
gonna be formed
we have found at the comic books the
Volks obviously this DC Comics it's
promising and there's lots of characters
in there you found a comics when you
were kid as well my brother was a huge
fan so therefore I didn't want to do
anything growing up I wanted to be the
queen opposite of my brother so he had
to teach me a lot about my character and
it was just it's nice toys you know it's
nice to play a sidekick and to kind of
you know fight crime and save you know
try to help help and save Starling city
Charles did you think we'll see more of
kind of Oliver and Roy together the kind
of sidekick kickin in
well I think that Roy's gonna have to go
through a little gamuts of he's gonna
have to go through a lot to experience
the level that Oliver has because Oliver
you know was fighting on the you know
was you know was plenty for his life for
five years so I'm thinking Roy's gonna
have to be put down a lot and beat down
before he gets built back up yeah just
doing thinking I know so we see Ritz
well we gotta see more ways to go in
theater there's a lot of more with Roy
and Thea a lot of heartbreak and also
some unexpected events put a kick kink
in their relationship
yeah I'm OTC currencies may be coming
into season two a lot of you're going to
see a lot of common characters that
people love coming into the this city
this world on our own so I wish I could
spoil a little more but I can what are
you most looking forward to fancy just
you know people continuing to enjoy the
comic books and we were sticking kind of
to the way the comics went but there was
three different ways of my character
could have gone and I think we're taking
the most severe is way